video games are all about agency players
having the ability to enact their will
within Virtual Worlds often without any
sexy constraints at least as long as
you're willing to grind hard enough
speaking of grinding though agency also
plays a large role in sex particularly
concerning consent which you need to
have good
sex
discussions of who can do what what we
can put where who likes what or what it
takes to reach the climax of The
Adventure are all discussions that
happen in both gaming and sex and all of
that gets even more complicated when we
talk about sex within gaming games
create interesting questions around
bodily autonomy and sexual consent
mainly because a group of people
developers set the rules and Define the
extent of agency that the player and
other people in the situation have
whether it's the wild freedom of Sex On
Demand in the open world of CD projekt
Red cyberpunk 2077 or the more linear
directed experience of double fine
Psychonauts 2. so what does consent mean
in video games where are the lines of
agency between the player and the
non-player character as well as the
developers and how is power defined in
the world's games allow us to inhabit so
um let's get comfortable and talk about
consent in video games and consider
whether we can do it better
thank you
so before we get uh deeper since we are
talking about consent let me tell you
what you're consenting to when you watch
this video obviously we'll be talking
about sex and sexual situations however
there will be no nudity there will
though be mentions of issues relating to
sexual assault though we won't be
describing anything in detail and since
we're talking about games we will have a
few minor spoilers for these games that
are on the screen right now though there
will be no major plot beats spoiled for
any of them and by telling you all what
will be in this video I've already
demonstrated an important part of
consent consent is all about making
clear and setting expectations of what
you can expect and allowing you to
choose to disengage such as if you
choose to stop watching this video due
to what I've described as its content
but what does all that look like in a
sexual context the simple definition of
sexual consent is someone actively and
emphasis on the word actively there
agreeing to have sex with someone both
parties must agree to a sexual act of
their own free will for it to be
consensual now that seems simple enough
but it gets more complicated because you
see in video games a common issue in how
consent is depicted is that it often
isn't as with many films and TV shows
characters will get ready to do the
naked Tango and then they'll just start
going for it take for example this scene
in Uncharted 2 with Chloe and Drake
Chloe climbs on top of Drake and even
puts his hand on her butt but he seems
surprised by this and she didn't ask if
it was okay for her to do that in
Assassin's Creed Brotherhood Katarina
just comes into Ezio's breath and starts
making out with him as the music as well
as presumably other things swell
[Music]
now all of this does not mean that these
are inherently bad sex scenes they're
actually quite good in a lot of cases
they showcase good character
interactions and highlight close
relationships that will be important to
the story later on and they're also just
a little bit uh steamy the problem is is
that these scenes depict consent as
implicit or something that happens off
screen and don't show people who play
the games what it looks like or it also
implies that sex is something that we're
supposed to Intuit that our partners are
interested in rather than actually
verbally communicating with them and sex
does and should take a lot of
communication and that's not a bad thing
nor a non-sexy thing when we discuss
consent we often see it as at odds with
romance or sexiness but in actuality
asking for consent can be incredibly
romantic
but quite often with most media and in
video games consent is often never
depicted on screen well certainly we can
assume these characters had spoken off
screen to communicate consent and
establish boundaries beforehand we never
actually get to see that and the problem
is that this is how most sex on screen
is portrayed and due to its
ubiquitousness means consent is often
treated like an afterthought in games
notably two these moments are often cut
scenes which act like movies or TV shows
where the choice to depict a sex act and
show consent within it is often solely
left to the creators authoring the
sequence another thing the Uncharted 2
scene highlights is how men are often
seen to consent simply by virtue of
being men Nathan Drake must want to have
his hands on clothes but because of
course he's a guy and he would want that
I thought you'd want to be in
on the action
[Music]
it's a subtle idea that underscores how
we in our society today often discuss
men as always wanting sex simply by
virtue of the fact that they are men and
it depicts women as withholding incent
just by the fact that they are women yet
not only is this dehumanizing to both
men and women it isn't true there's an
implicit message in our society that men
are somehow less manly if they don't
want sex they must always want it having
sex and a lot of it is a measure of
one's masculinity but in reality it's
okay for men to not always want sex and
it's okay to turn down sex even if
someone else wants it from you as I said
before sex requires enthusiastic consent
from every participant who chooses to
engage in it and Games should reflect
this reality
however unlike movies and TV shows
gaming is about player control and the
player can sometimes play a role in
choosing to have consent in sex in a
game take for example heavy rain when
you're not hunting for the Origami
Killer the two leads Ethan and Madison
can get nice and close and sexy but as
Madison leans in for a kiss the Game
Stops and lets the player who is
controlling Ethan choose to kiss the
girl or not while the characters never
verbalize the discussion of consent the
player gets a choice if they wish to
engage or not and also thereby
tangentially allowing the male character
to choose to consent or not sadly
Madison's agency doesn't get much
thought in the game which may indicate
certain creators behind the scenes
issues around women but it also goes to
show that in a scene about sex you're
depicted as playing the man not the
woman and this goes again to how often
women in media are often picked it as
the object in sex not something or
someone with agency overall though this
is a great scene as it highlights a
player's agency in the moment but one
issue is that it depicts consent as a
simple yes or no once you click yes I
wish to engage in sex the sex begins
with neither character having any
conversations after that however with
all sex it's not usually yeah go ahead
you can do whatever you want with my
body now that we've started instead most
sex during the act itself is all about
asking questions and communicating with
each other what do you like what can I
do is this okay do you like this can I
touch that can I go there
on top of all this consent doesn't have
to happen in the moment it can be talked
about well before sex even happens even
minutes hours days weeks months before
for example if your romance my boy
Garrus in Mass Effect 2 our beautiful
turian sets up a plan with Shepard to do
the naked tango I'll find some music and
do some research to figure out how this
thing should work it'll either be a
night to treasure or a horrible inner
species awkwardness thing
in which case fighting the collectors
will be a welcome distraction so you
know a win either way
from there he even asked if he can
research human sexuality leading to his
adorable nervousness if you were a
turian I'd be complimenting your waste
or
Orange
hair
looks good and your waist is
very supportive yet he learns and works
with Shepard about what a human woman
may want and desire and it's clearly
appreciated I know um
I appreciated it sadly though the game
Fades to Black before sex happens after
all that teasing we didn't even get to
see those hot calibrations
calibrating a giant gun is a vacation on
top of Garris which is also incidentally
where many of us would like to be Mass
Effect 2 will often centralize the
player's agency and desire and sexual
situations over the other participants
the non-player characters for example
while Gara spent a lot of time learning
what Shepard would want Shepard never
takes time to learn what Garris would
want I mean my favorite lizard Boy
Deserves some attention after everything
uh yeah I hung out a lot of places last
night
your upper body your lower body pretty
much all the parts in between
[Music]
however rarely do non-player characters
agencies get highlighted in games for
example throughout the Mass Effect
series you as Shepherd get a myriad of
romance options from sexy blue aliens to
sexy green aliens But ultimately it's
your choice who you get to Bone before
your final mission because pretty much
everyone as long as they're of
asexuality that is interested in your
gender is DTF okay while you do have to
build a relationship with each character
by speaking to them several times before
they'll jump in the sack with you the
understanding that most games have going
in is that these discussions will lead
to sex as the climax of the relationship
as such you know what you're building
towards each time you interact with a
character there's no possibility for
example to end up in a relationship with
someone where sex happens on the first
date or not at all it's all about
leading to sex not only can this come
across as though you're trying to earn
sex by having conversations rather than
earnestly getting to know them but also
de-emphasizes the the non-player
character's choice to have or not have
sex as you enter into the conversation
already expecting sex if that's what you
want from them something predetermined
as the outcome rather than it being
something agreed upon by both parties
because games allow players to interact
with the world around them the Player's
Choice is prioritized and NPCs are there
to facilitate the player rather than
having any recognizable agency of their
own and this can even happen in our real
world discussions of a game's character
for example the character of Judy in
cyberpunk 2077 is a lesbian and will
only desire to romance characters who
both identify as a woman and have a
female body type though interestingly
you can have a penis showing that Judy
does view trans women as women yet
Beyond this some players who chose to
play as a male protagonist were upset
that Judy wasn't a romance option for
them I reached out to cyberpunk 2077's
narrative director Igor sarzinski to
discuss this phenomenon I think the best
the best sex scene we have is the one
with Jody a female partner for queer
character she also has her preferences
she wouldn't romance any anyone else
something we actually got some slack for
from players that oh I'm a guy where I
cannot promise Judy she's so cool like
because she has a preference it's not
all about you and I think this worked
pretty nicely cyberpunk 2077 views Judy
as an entire person someone with desires
and preferences Beyond simply the need
to satisfy the player's desires this
caused dissonance for some players
though because often we aren't forced to
think about NPC's agencies as people
within the game's Universe we tend to
think of NPCs as being around for us not
as living for their own sake with their
own preferences and perspectives and
lives and to a degree this is partially
true NPCs within video games are quite
literally made for the player to
interact with
but this attitude around NPCs often
underscores a similar feeling of how we
can dehumanize real-life people in
disgusting consent such as for example
how many women will be seen as wanting
it simply for wearing a certain type of
clothing yet with Judy and cyberpunk her
sexual preference is set before sex
would even be possible for the player
it's always like this tension between
what you want to do as a Creator and
what is the expectation of the player
you cannot go too much against him
because like people just wouldn't like
their game because they expect something
else and at the same time as a Creator
you want to say something and you don't
want to just like give people everything
they want and we try to find this
balance so again we try to provide
something for everyone but at the same
time we wanted to do kind of on our Like
rules let's say and that's why we wanted
characters to have clear preferences and
just actually this makes them like a
character that is someone with some
boundaries and some again preferences if
all the non-player characters would just
cater to players players needs it makes
them just not sharp enough not clear
enough as like their own separate people
and this is also what makes them
authentic I think that they you know
they have their own like statements and
ideas and opinions about the world and
not just oh yes player I'll do whatever
you want like
um so I think it allowed us to create
stronger characters that they actually
want this and don't want something else
and mass effect as well also showcased
this for example if you can't have sex
with Garris as a male Shepherd as Garrus
is only interested in women however
cyberpunk takes this further the game
showcases a scene where an NPC who is
sexually interested in you draws
consensual boundaries but more
interestingly does so during the
Romantic situation itself yeah so
actually there's a great example of a
scene that's like we had a lot of
discussions around consent there's this
side quest when you know like John
overtakes your body and takes his former
love interest Rogue to a date and then
like everything in the game tells you
like it's it's moving in this direction
like this is what's gonna happen in the
end and so they're like both into it
really trying to to do it but they have
both changed or actually broke has
changed the most so the sex scene kinda
starts they start to kiss there's some
action and we almost move on to like you
know taking clothes off and drug is like
no you know actually I cannot do it like
it doesn't doesn't feel right Johnny I
can't
it's not right
and it was super tricky like this moment
to not feel um rapey I guess is the word
like we had a lot of discussions how to
show that she tries to be into it but
really deep inside she isn't and at some
moment she like places the boundary uh
you know that's like it cannot go on
for sure it was super important for like
the player character to react to it
really like in a respectful way not
trying to push her not to move into this
yeah you know slimy area
let's say and thus I really love the
scene because I I think like the
subversing this expectation of like sex
will have to happen actually it worked
great for telling something about
characters and about Rogue who wants to
go back but then she like she learns
that she cannot redo it that she has
changed as a person and that like you
cannot really go back in time this scene
ultimately becomes about Rogue realizing
her boundaries and setting them for
Johnny and it comes out of an emotional
and realistic place for her Johnny who
the player currently controls wants to
have sex but he respects her boundaries
in a game that literally sold itself on
giving players access to do whatever
they wanted to do like no game before
it's a noticeable moment where the game
limits the player and has the player
respect in NPC's desires not the players
on top of this we can even add another
layer as the scene is also built upon
Johnny asking permission to use V's body
have fun you crazy kids
and even points that out when Rogue
turns him down mean and not fair to V
not fair to you it's also interesting to
note though that Igor stated in the
interview that sex not being on the
table was a subversion of expectations
which also subtly points to the fact
that sex is often an expectation or an
inevitability in games this speaks to
how generally culturally we often think
of consent as an assumed yes until told
otherwise when in actuality it should be
the opposite we should assume no until
we're told otherwise
however sadly and anger-inducingly
respecting stated boundaries is not
always depicted well in media media
frequently depicts a pursuit of a yes
trying to get someone to consent who has
already stated no already I can't rely
on say kiss me
[Music]
kiss me many Studies have shown that how
sex is depicted in media can influence
how we think of and conceive of sex in
real life especially considering that
sex and media will be the first time
that many of us encounter sex so
highlighting sex is an assumed yes and
not respecting stated boundaries can
lead to this sentiment being reflected
in real life sexual situations because
that's how people think it's supposed to
be done but games complicate this even
further by implicating us as players who
have agency within sexual situations as
players often have control in these
situations they're not just passive
observers like they are in TVs and
movies games like Leisure Suit Larry
often have you try to coerce women into
sex despite them repeatedly telling you
no as a result games like this allow the
player to not see yeses yes and no is no
but instead know as a potential yes if
you work hard enough which directly
disrespects someone's stated boundaries
it makes the player complicit in the act
of ignoring consent and thus can
normalize it as okay to do so and this
problem with not depicting consent isn't
solely limited to sexual consent and
sexual situations whether a situation is
sexual or not is important that we all
have agency in being able to choose what
we do and what others do with our bodies
in the original Psychonauts the player
character Raz would enter other
characters Minds without permission so
is this where I get a speech and learn
another lesson no here's your merit
badge let us never speak of this again
he even often enters the minds of people
who cannot give informed consent given
their mental state not another tracking
device it's quite literally invasive but
by the time we got to Psychonauts 2 the
implicit invasiveness of braz's power
became much more top of mind for Creator
Tim Schaefer yeah well there was a big
time difference between the first and
second psychotic scan the first game you
know we I was younger we were just you
know making stuff up because we went and
hadn't thought about a lot of issues and
um on this the second game we were doing
I think it came out of our work from the
the Hollis level hollis's hot streak
where Raz goes into some deep into
someone's mind and actually messes with
things that are not his domestically he
oversteps the bounds and it's part of
his his one of the lessons he learns in
this game but he learns that he has so
much power that he can cause harm that
he didn't realize he could cause
[Music]
uh-oh and when I was working on that
level I realized wow this power to go
into people's minds which is the
foundation of psychots it's really
invasive like it's very invasive
incredibly like you know seeing people's
dreams like you wouldn't think of
reading someone's diary or their dream
diary but like going into someone's mind
and then making changes very invasive
and it just seemed wrong to do it
without explicit permission do you think
Bob would mind if I took a look inside
his mind
that was that was the extent of the the
thought process behind it it just feels
wrong to to go so invasively in someone
else's
um personal space literally their mind
and and to make any changes especially
even just going in to look around and
seeing invasive enough to require
explicit permission
went away this asking for consent on
raz's part in Psychonauts 2 is in a way
the game criticizing the first game in
the series ignoring of consent razza's
need to learn to ask for permission to
enter people's minds becomes a part of
his character's Arc within the game I
feel like the world has changed and we
have all changed and it's been you know
in the last 15 years I think thought
about things that at least on a personal
level that
um hadn't yet encountered or talked
about so much openly back in uh back in
those days bodies on loan from the mail
room
hang on borrowed lips wouldn't be right
but it wasn't like you know in this game
I'm gonna you know teach these lessons
it was more just in writing these
characters these are the situations that
were presented and the moral choices
that were presented and they just seemed
to call for a certain treatment so I
felt like an organically came out of the
subject matter of the story that we're
telling I I violated your trust
very idea of what it means to
be ready for this after all you're right
about violating trust what you did was
wrong very wrong
but
truth is
I pulled it similar stunt once really
all of this showcases how games can
begin to subvert problems in their
earlier depictions and how it's also not
necessarily wrong to show characters
failing at consent as long as the
narrative critiques it rather than
simply taking it for granted as it was
in the first game life is strange true
colors for example does something
similar in the game you have the power
to read people's emotional states
however at one point in the game you're
placed in a scenario that involves the
character Charlotte a widow who lost her
partner due to an incident involving her
child at one point you're allowed a
choice to take away Charlotte's
resentment and anger at her child yet
you would do so without Charlotte
knowing if you choose to do this as the
player however Charlotte was unable to
feel any real emotions for the rest of
the game
it's like when your leg falls asleep
and even though it's still attached
comes something other than you
my whole life
I've always felt so deeply
but
Maybe
this is better
it won't be on your side if the story's
climax there's something wrong with you
Alex
[Music]
and now there's something wrong with me
your forcible denial of Charlotte's
bodily autonomy leads her to a form of
disassociation and PTSD which can often
occur when people's ability to consent
is denied however if you respect
Charlotte's bodily autonomy and let her
keep her emotions she'll be on your side
later on which is presented as a
positive outcome as a result life is
strange allows the player's choices to
become part of the commentary of the
game showcasing the ramifications
directly for the Player's actions
without taking away the player's ability
to respect someone's bodily autonomy or
not but this all leads us to our final
question because we've mainly been
talking about consent between players
and NPCs but what about between the
players and the developers because you
see that too is a relationship in which
the developers often have more power and
Grant agency to the player they quite
literally build the worlds that we
inhabit within a game and pick what
choices we have or don't have they
literally have the power to decide what
amount of agency we have Within in these
worlds and thus the amount of stuff that
we're able to consent to Within A Game's
world for example in that situation in
life is strange true colors you aren't
given an option to ask Charlotte if she
wants to have her emotions taken away or
not what if she had said yes but the
developers didn't program that as an
option taking away players Agency for
the sake of the story that they wish to
tell and these are all choices that
developers make in every single game
that's just how games are made you can't
put every single option within a world
into a game because that would basically
be nigh impossible for a developer to
program we're not making The Matrix here
at least not yet hopefully but if that's
the case what if we started considering
these developers choices in terms of
consent what do players consent to when
they enter into a game based on what the
developers have made for them what
choices are the developers put in front
of them that they may choose to or not
choose to take part in this question
lied at the heart of a genuine concern
in 2021 with Kit Fox games boyfriend
dungeon a Dungeon Crawler where you date
personified versions of your weapons in
the game however you meet the blacksmith
Eric who turns out to be a manipulative
and aggressive stalker no matter what
you do he will follow you text you and
come after you mirroring how real life
stalkers often work to limit the agency
of their victims but the game was
controversial not because of this
storyline alone but because players
weren't prepared for it many players
didn't know that this storyline was in
the game and so we're shocked to
discover that it was there and as a
result many players took to Twitter to
voice that they hadn't consented to a
storyline about a stalker which may have
caused distress to many who would had
that experience in real life and then
played the game without warning I did
not consent to this I know for some
games this is just par for the course
but it's 2021 and I didn't ask boyfriend
dungeon to place me into an extremely
distressing situation which from what I
can tell I cannot opt out of many
pointed out that the game's content
warning didn't adequately warn about
this particular storyline leading the
developer to quickly fix this by failing
to have a comprehensive content warning
the game's developers didn't allow the
players the full informed Choice topped
in or out of the story to choose to play
the game or not if they didn't want to
engage with that type of storyline
Psychonauts 2 also had an extensive and
clear content warning something Tim
Schaefer worked hard to get right even
making sure he consulted with people
outside of himself just to get the
wording of the disclaimer correct to
ensure players knew exactly what they
were in for and what needed to be
expressed to them before playing yeah I
think that was a really positive
experience I wrote that and consulted it
with Dr B from uh pick this and it
changed with the input from the fan some
of the early tests and fans added things
like that vomit could be a triggering
thing for August I never would occurred
to me there are other things in the game
that could be upset I knew that the
dental horror I knew some of the people
on the original team had a very stronger
version could do going to the dentist
and I know that's a that's a deep Health
thing for people so that one went in
automatically and then some of the other
ones were um added just in just people
saying like hey by the way it slows out
of doing art like if you make art you're
always thinking making connection with
people and about uh you know expressing
something emotional and something
creative and having other people have a
reaction to it so you're always thinking
about what a reaction you'd want to have
not that you can control that but you're
like I'm making a horror film so I want
people to feel scared right here I'm
making a love story I want people to
feel romantic right here like you you
are trying to you know bring someone
certain emotions and so you probably
don't have the emotional you don't
probably don't have the intent of saying
like right here I want to do lasting
psychological harms I want to make
someone remember the worst period of
their life or something like you know
you don't usually have those intense so
so
um it's just you you you always are
thinking about your audience the impact
you have on them and that mental health
advisory is just a natural expression of
that oh
is that all good
I thought it was something more worrying
like kissing moving on many people also
took issue with boyfriend dungeon
further arguing that the stalker
storyline should be removed entirely
rather than it be something simply
divulged in the content warning of the
game yet the stalker storyline was
essential to what the developers wanted
to depict with their narrative this
choice to take part in that narrative
should be informed yes which a Content
warning allows for additionally you can
and should critique What A Game's story
or message is and you can argue that you
find it harmful or wrong but this
storyline in boyfriend dungeon's whole
point is to discuss stalking and
removing it because you didn't consent
to the story being there ignores that it
was the story that developers wanted to
tell but this isn't as black and white
as it first appears because what if the
story The developers wanted to tell goes
against the choices that they had given
to the player earlier in the game about
the sexual agency that the gamers had
made for example Assassin's Creed
Odyssey allowed you to play as a boy or
girl and many players chose to play
their female player character as gay
having their Cassandra date Only Women
Within the game yet the game's DLC
Legacy of the first blade ended by
forcing Gamers into a heterosexual
relationship directly denying players
choices of their sexuality that they had
made earlier Gamers got so upset by this
that Ubisoft even apologized for
removing players agency that they had
previously given and on top of all of
this what if Gamers want to play a game
but don't want to consent to violent or
sexual imagery within it for example
Monte cook gaming published a tabletop
RPG guide called consenting gaming that
outlines rules for creating games that
are affirming for all even creating
checklists that someone could give to
their DM to say what they are and aren't
comfortable with before they start
playing and video games are implementing
similar changes to accessibility
settings allowing players to turn off
blood or sexual imagery or more within
the options menu which is fantastic and
this also creates a gray area because
certainly while sometimes blood in a
game for example isn't needed but a nice
bit of immersion that a player can
choose to engage with or not what if
seeing excessive amounts of blood or
sexual imagery is part of the story the
game is trying to tell and turning it
off would make the game's story have
been communicated less effectively if
really at all for example The Last of Us
Part 2 is a game in part about how
excessive violence towards others leads
us to dehumanize them so would being
able to turn off Ellie's brutal
stabbings damage the effectiveness of
the game's message
this became a controversy recently
surrounding the game Dead Space which
gave content warnings within the game
and allowed players to turn them on if
they wish to this was an amazing Choice
by the developers of the Dead Space
remake because it allowed players the
chance to choose whether or not they
wish to engage with imagery that might
cause them some form of distress giving
players more accessibility choices like
this is amazing because it allows
players to be able to consent to what
they wish to within a game but this can
also go the other way too what if a
player wishes to turn something off due
to a bias or a bigotry for example what
if someone demands an option to turn off
having to see lgbtq people within a game
for instance in fact The Sims 4 recently
added sexual orientations to their
character creator and some people
demanded that they be allowed to turn it
off to which the devs responded can you
turn this feature off no while we try to
give players the option to toggle
certain gameplay features
lgbtqia plus identities are a fact of
life and not a toggle to be switched on
and off which is a fantastic response
and in fact I actually spoke to the Sims
character creator developer about
writing this response and their thinking
behind it whenever we add a feature that
substantively changes the gameplay Loop
in The Sims the discussion that always
comes up is whether or not we should
allow it to be toggled on and off and we
were firm early on that this wasn't
something that we wanted to be a toggle
in the times we're living in
cause strong passive as affirmations of
the queer Community are really important
and I think we wanted to make sure that
we stood by the community by making this
choice and I think it's one of those
things where what kind of message does
it send if we add like a representation
feature and people just turn it off
right like but that's not really the
message we want to send so that's that's
where that came from yet given the
current demonization and politicization
of trans and queer identities one could
easily see a developer wanting to avoid
any controversy and not being so Direct
in their response in fact this quite
recently happened with the video game
Hogwarts Legacy where people ask the
developers specifically about the
transgender controversies relating to JK
Rowling in the Harry Potter World and
sadly the developers didn't come out and
say that they supported trans people
just that they supported all people's
rights this is sadly a really
disappointing response because it's not
really directly talking about the issue
and not making their stance clear around
whether or not they support Tran trans
people and this isn't to say that the
people who said this statement were
anti-trans or transphobic or anything
like that but just pointing to the fact
that they aren't able to directly
confront the controversy because they
don't want to affect sales of their
games but it leads to people not talking
about issues pertaining to marginalized
communities such as the trans community
in this case it's something we often see
for example with the censorship or
denial or hiding of lgbtq characters in
film and media in general where is the
line where the player's agency takes
precedent and the story The developers
wish to tell begins in these situations
and the only answer we can give
is that there's no clear answer we're
talking about art and art frankly defies
clear black and white distinctions quite
often but most importantly a player's
most significant moment of consent is
choosing to play a game at all and
giving players as much knowledge
beforehand helps with that decision no
one owes any game their attention or
Focus we get to choose whether we engage
with it or not and giving us as much
knowledge beforehand around that game
the context of the game and what's
within the game helps players know
whether they can choose to engage with
it be it through content warnings
marketing or accessibility options all
of that helps with that choice but also
stories that challenge us and push us
outside of our comfort zones can be
helpful to us but it also gets us back
to consent and how we should be the ones
to dictate our bodies as all of this
shows consent is both a complicated and
a straightforward topic simultaneously
it's very simple in that it's all about
respecting someone's wishes for their
own body and that's it and listening to
what they have to say about themselves
and respecting that and giving them as
much agency as possible around their own
body
yet consent does become complicated
because of our own biases and limits on
our ability to empathize with others
that can often obfuscate that ability to
listen and respect others as well as the
fact that within games we're literally
creating worlds and as a result we have
to constantly be thinking about what
abilities we are allowing the players to
have when it comes to their agency
gaming provides an excellent and unique
Avenue to discuss consent because it's
all about navigating agency and desire
more so than any other medium but games
are also influenced by our biases as
well as our willingness to use games as
fantasy and seeing others as literal
non-player characters and making
invisible things that should be outright
stated at the end of the day though
our understanding of consent and gaming
has come a long way we've gone from
taking consent as implicit implied or
even outright ignored to making
understanding consent a part of the
story but there's still a long way to go
like men being seen as always consenting
to the idea that coercing consent is
acceptable and even beyond that there
are some issues that may never be
answered as their core to the questions
of games as an artistic medium and art
in general all art and especially pop
culture influence our understanding of
sex and consent so perhaps more so than
any other medium gaming is the most
necessary place to get consent right
because both are all about agency gaming
allows us the most human chance to
understand the importance of consent in
a way that not only informs how we think
about it but can allow us to practice
how it works in real time in the end
consent like games is all about figuring
out how best to navigate the world in
front of you to trust those around you
and use the tools you're given and
respect how others use their tools and
like any game you get better at consent
as you learn how to use your tools to
enter into the Flow State because as I
said consent is always required and it
can always be sexy
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]